okay so we are back with Carnage and you
guys are gonna have to bear with me I'm
a little under the weather so I
apologize if I'm not my normal excited
self but what this does is this
basically focuses on Carnage becoming
the god breaker in one of the coolest
ways ever so what this does is this
initially opens up by talking about the
nature of nadavalier right kind of the
weapons forging place for virtually all
the gods in existence and what it shows
us is that nadavalier is effectively a
tomb now this is one part due to the war
of the Realms and one part due to the
god of hammer storyline now the war of
Realms we've talked about the war with
malakith and all that kind of stuff the
god of hammers was relatively new you
guys will find a link to the Thor
playlist down in the comment section so
you can get caught up on that story if
you're interested but the idea behind
God of hammers is that it built on the
origin that had already been established
about mjolnir itself that in years past
it was believed that mjolnir was just a
hammer forged by the dwarves using uru
metal and then had the enchantment
placed on it by Odin that only those who
were worthy can lift it what we had
learned recently was that within the
hammer itself was quite literally a
cosmic entity that had been harnessed by
Odin and was the source of the Hammer's
power hence the reason why it was able
to do such incredible things and why
more recently when Jane Foster became
Thor in what I consider to be the
greatest Thor run ever told that the
hammer was able to choose her and no one
else could lift it if the hammer didn't
want them to so kind of giving it a
personality of sorts but during the god
of hammer storyline nadavalier at least
what was left of it was basically
eradicated right like all the dwarves
are by all standards of measurement dead
or were more or less dead I mean there
are still some that are there but it
doesn't quite matter because once
Carnage gets here he kills everybody
right now remember Carnage is on a quest
for godhood but we don't really know
exactly what the end goal is he's just
kind of grabbing these little bits and
pieces here and there but all of it
comes to a head in this story and we
find out exactly what it is he's been
getting all these bits and pieces for
now with Carnage showing up here and
laying waste to virtually all the gods
or at least all the dwarves that are
here in existence what he ends up doing
is approaching a cell and when he gets
there the person within that cell
immediately tells him just so you know
before you ask your questions the answer
is going to be no because I know why
you're here you're here for the same
reason that anybody else has come here
looking for me and I'm always going to
tell you no just like I told them no
right and literally Carnage says I want
you to forge me a weapon right to make a
fearsome weapon the likes of which all
of existence has never seen before so
it's kind of cool but in fact Carnage is
lying to a degree because the weapon
he's talking about is going to be a
weapon that we've seen before and I
think you guys are gonna are gonna freak
when you find out what this weapon is
because it's gonna be one of the coolest
things but of course the response of
this guy is just definitively and
resolutely no that's never going to
happen now the funny thing about this is
that in the last story arc that we did
when Carnage had traveled to the realm
of hell and faced off against hella one
of the things that she had said is that
if they're able to travel here to
nadavalier and they're able to enlist
this guy's Health he would do it for his
freedom and his life they basically
agree to set him free to go about his
life doing his thing and that would be
enough of a barter and so initially his
response is still no and in fact he even
says my name is Jordan runehauer he's
basically the brother of Eatery now
Eatery is like the king of the dwarves
and one of the things that I want to
establish here is that one of the big uh
I guess maybe misconceptions of the
dwarves in the Thor Mythos is that they
serve the asgardians not really right
the dwarves are just kind of like their
own group of people who do their own
thing and they're well known for forging
weapons but they're not really beholden
to the asgardians it just happens to be
that because they're so good at forging
weapons the asgardians are always
hitting them up but the light elves hit
up the dwarves as well along with like
trolls trolls have done the same thing
right like anybody out there who's
looking for incredible arms and Armament
will always go to the dwarves an
adavalier because they're the best
weapons forgers in existence but what he
says here is that in his mind and the
reason why he's even in prison in the
first place is because he spoke out
against eatery that over the years
whenever any group came to the dwarves
for manufacturing weapons they would
always use them for like nefarious
purposes they would always use them for
war and different things like that but
the reality here is that building
weapons is just one of the things that
dwarves are capable of doing they can
also build incredible tools and
instruments of building as opposed to
destroying but nobody ever seeks them
for that and so the response of drawing
was to say we should just shut it all
down like we should just end the forge
and everything because this will never
end and in fact given the level of
fighting that took place during like the
war of Realms and all that kind of stuff
which almost laid waste to the entirety
of the Realms as we know them all we're
doing here is supplying weapons that
will ultimately at some point lead to
our own destruction so we should stop
and so the response of Carnage is I
totally get where you're coming from
that makes perfect sense but what if I
told you that the weapon that you're
going to craft for me is a weapon that I
would use to wipe out the gods to end
anybody out there that would try to hit
you guys up for instruments of war to
remove and to destroy any of their
opposition out there this would be your
final weapon the final weapon created by
the dwarves themselves and so ultimately
drawing ends up signing on board with
what Carnage wants to do and so
following this we switch over to John
shade right now John shade ever the
detective has basically just been on the
hunt for Carnage ever since things
popped off in the beginning the funny
thing about this is that being imbued
with a portion of the Carnage symbiote
itself while it's not enough to overtake
Jon it has taken him on an adventure
that he could just never really even
begin to comprehend in his life before
all of this had gone on and so even in
his conversations with a piece of the
Symbiote itself he kind of comes to this
realization there is no going back that
what he's experienced here by virtue of
this adventure is a paradigm shift that
he has been irrevocably changed so even
if everything all calms back down the
story arc ends he goes back to his life
as a detective he'll always kind of
daydream about grander Adventures
because he's been there before he's been
down that road before so it's kind of
cool but again he's still stuck in the
realm of hella and so what he ends up
doing is traveling to basically one of
the portals that's guarded by one of the
frost Giants that's effectively died and
then been sent to hell and so initially
he's told you cannot pass here but the
funny thing about the Carnage symbiote
talking to him or at least a little
facsimile of it is that it kind of calls
him a coward and it calls him to
question whether or not he's willing to
do whatever it is that he needs to do in
order to come out on top and that flies
in the face of everything that John
shade knows and so the thing that he
comes to this realization here is it
doesn't matter right he wants to find
Carnage he has to do whatever it takes
to find Carnage which means killing this
guy on the spot
literally he kills him just right there
and it's kind of nuts because following
that he ends up passing through the
portal and seeking out the main Carnage
symbia now because this little portion
of the Symbiote is tab or at least it's
part of the main Carnage itself that
ultimately it knows where Carnage is
right like he's able to just kind of hit
on it as a beacon and so it ends up
leading John shade to nadavelier and so
following this we end up switching back
over to drawing and to Kenneth Neely now
remember Kenneth Neely is the guy who
was obsessed with the idea of Carnage he
was basically trying to get his
attention and really have like a false
perception of what the Symbiote was
about he learned pretty fast that this
version of Carnage is drastically
different than the one that he knew and
in fact we'll talk about that over the
course of this video but what ends up
happening is drouin comes to this
realization or maybe he even knew it
when Carnage initially hit him up in the
first place that this weapon Carnage
intends to have created is not going to
be used strictly for the elimination of
any gods and anyone out there that Drew
and simply just doesn't want to make
weapons for the Carnage is going to turn
it against everybody right which
includes Kenneth Andrew and himself and
so if for no other reason then most
likely self-preservation Jordan comes up
with this plan and what he does is he
tells Kenneth about the nature of the
forge of nadavalier and what he tells
him is that when it comes to just
crafting any arbitrary weapon that's out
there they usually just pull in like a
star quite literally Stars flying
overhead the forge pulls one of the
stars in but when it comes to crafting
weapons of significance something like
uru metal the hammer of Thor which is
made from Uber metal that they actually
pull in something like 50 stars but he
says they have to be careful about it
because if they pull in too many suns it
would actually destroy the entirety of
the davalere because it wouldn't be able
to contain that much energy but the fact
remains of what he says is that there is
no uru medal on the davalere anymore
it's all been spent it's all gone so the
idea of crafting this Uber weapon for
Carnage is a ruse he literally lied to
him like yeah we'll craft your weapon
for you but the entire intention of this
is to open the forge to make it look
like he's building something of
significance but in reality what he
intends to do is pull in something like
50 or 60 stars and just destroy the
Carnage symbiote using the power of heat
and pressure which would actually work
right because remember one of the big
weaknesses of Symbiotes is heat itself
following that he breaks out a kind of
multi-dimensional Rubik's Cube that
would basically allow them to travel
anywhere they desire throughout the
entirety of the Multiverse now one of
the big limitations here this is one of
the things that I want to specify when I
use the phrase Multiverse in relation to
the Thor Mythos we're really just
talking about different Realms and
dimensions and so what ends up happening
here is that when drawing asks Carnage
what weapon am I making for you right
what is it that you want me to crash the
response of Carnage is you will craft
for me a weapon designed to kill gods in
years past they call it all black the
necro sword the butcher's blade
literally he's recrafting the weapon of
null the Symbiote God which is dope like
it's ridiculously cool right this is one
of the coolest things ever so I was
really excited to see this because in
reality while no the Symbiote God was
able to use the sword to like kill
celestials and so on this weapon in the
hands of Carnage would lead to the ruin
of all like it would lead to the
destruction of anybody and everybody and
so following this as the weapon is in
the process of being forged or at least
the initial process is taking place
Carnage of course growing impatient
demands to know how long it's going to
take and that's when drawing and Kenneth
make their move and they say it's almost
complete the the construction process
begins now they ultimately open the
forge they pull in 50 Suns and they all
descend on Carnage and they kill them
they destroy the Carnage symbiote on the
spot like it literally eradicates the
entirety of the Symbian because it's
like having Carnage thrown into just
like a super sun composed of 50 Suns the
Heat and the pressure is enough to
completely and totally wipe this guy out
of existence and so what's kind of crazy
is that drawing makes this commentary
right he says do you really think having
denied the gods themselves I would lower
this Forge to some base Pursuit Of
Violence oh you can squirm and lash and
whip all you want but there is nothing
in all existence except uru metal that
can absorb the amount of energy coursing
through you right now and there has not
been any in this Forge not since the
dwarves who worked it perished this is
it this is how you die if even a moat of
you continue to exist after a few
moments it would be a miracle but this
is basically completely and totally
thrown into disarray when John shade
shows up and this is the reason why
remember Carnage gave John shade a
portion of his own Symbian and so when
John shade shows up here the Carnage
symbiote that's basically being
eradicated reaches out to John shade and
whether or not Jon does it of his own
accord or because he's forced to do it
by the Symbian we're not given a
definitive answer to but once the two of
them make contact while the main
symbiote itself seems to be destroyed if
basically able to regrow itself using
the portion that it got from John shade
and the entire plan is no it's all gone
right it's literally over Carnage lives
on and the first thing he does is kill
drawing just like that but then he in
turn thinks about what it was that
Jordan told him right there is no uru
metal on this place not since the
dwarves who had forged it had all been
destroyed and so what Carnage does is he
seeks out the body of every dwarf on
nadavalier realizing that in forging uru
metal they would have had bits and
pieces of it on them and by sorting
through the entirety of their bodies and
absorbing those little fragments of uru
metal into them under their fingernails
on their skin and their hair the whole
nine yards he's able to piece together
enough uru metal to get what he wants
but doing this and using the uru metal
in turn Carnage bonds it to himself now
that's a big difference here is because
initially what it looked like is all
Carnage wanted to do was have an uru
Metal Blade that would have been
equivalent at least in durability to
Thor's Hammer with the power that was
wielded under null meaning that Carnage
as he stands now assuming that we can
argue he is in effect a walking talking
all black necro sword is now comparable
in power to a Celestial he's able to
wipe a Celestial out of existence it
doesn't mean he can necessarily create
life on like a universal scale or
anything like that but in terms of
durability and destructive force this
guy's God level now right there's a
reason why he's called the god breaker
Carnage like it's just this ridiculously
amazing Revelation for his character now
the other part of this is that because
John shade was the one that seemingly
defied All Odds and showed up here in
order to confront Carnage The Carnage in
turn basically betrays Kenneth that he'd
kind of been leading Kenneth on this
entire time and said I will eventually
make you my host assuming that you were
able to withstand you have the stomach
for all the things that we're going to
be doing here so that's kind of why
Kenneth was following him around like a
little puppy this whole time he wanted
to become the new host for Carnage But
ultimately because of John Shea just
proving his medal Carnage decides Jon
will be the new host and in this moment
with Kenneth realizing he's about to die
he snatches up the cube and then
basically punches in a series of
coordinates and takes off basically
traveling to the one person that he
knows is able to destroy Carnage he
arrives at Saint Agnes orphanage where
Cletus Cassidy resides now remember
Cletus Cassidy and Carnage had been
separated for quite some time but Cletus
Cassidy was able to harness the power of
one of these symbiote dragons that
belonged to null he effectively merged
with it so he doesn't really have a
physical form instead by taking control
of the Symbiote and traveling back to
the orphanage he is able to basically
alter and control all of reality within
this house like he controls it all there
he is effectively God and So within
reason given the fact that he also
possesses the extrembia right like the
extreme symbiote as it was called by
Marvel this guy really is the only one
who can challenge Carnage which really
begs the question what happens when we
get to a point where Cletus Cassidy has
to fight the Carnage symbia and with the
two heightened levels of power that
these guys have what would happen if
they merged because you basically have
two guys who are in different different
degrees comparable to the power of null
the Symbiote God who almost killed the
Marvel Universe two people with that
level of power merging into one it would
seemingly amplify their power two three
maybe even four times over again so with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace